hi everyone my name is Colin Fulton day
is my preferred pronoun I work for a
company called duo security which is a
division of Cisco we're a cloud security
company really awesome place to work if
you're looking for work feel free to
talk to me afterwards
I put my twitter handle github and email
up there honestly I don't really use
twitter that much so if you want to get
in touch with me email is generally the
better way but you know if you
absolutely have to tweet about things
you can go ahead and use that twitter
handler alright so who is this talk for
it's really difficult to put together a
talk on a rather esoteric subject like
this because the audience is generally
pretty split between people who have
absolutely no idea how any of this stuff
works and people who know way more about
it than me so I've tried to add some
content for people who may not have
gotten a degree in computer science for
example I actually got a degree in art
and design and theater and who want to
learn a bit more about how computers
work under the hood and how vintage
computers used to work but I also tried
to add some more historical context as
well as more advanced information about
implementation details for people who
are looking at the more technical side
of this and who may actually know a
little bit about how these old computers
work so well preparing this talk I
noticed that on the strange loop home
page it said meet us in st. Louis to
make connections with the creators and
users of languages libraries tools and
techniques at the forefront of the
industry I find this hilarious because
the computer that's hooked up the
projector right now for the rest this
presentation is going to be used just
for my presentation notes the rest of my
slides are on this five and a quarter
inch floppy disk on which I have encoded
all my slides and a 200 byte assembly
program which acts as slide presentation
software
all right I'm gonna go ahead and pop
that disc in the drive switch over the
HDMI cable
make sure this is up and running and I'm
going to once this boots up again there
we go there we go the lovely sound of
floppy disco days now if I run the
catalog command here oops and spell
correctly it's going to print out all
the different files on this the whole
file there is just a basic initially
initialization script that kind of holds
the actual operating system to load off
disk and then there is a file called
slide so if I run the binary run command
be run on the file slides it's gonna
load that off disk I promise it's
loading there we go all right so here we
go so what is this talk gonna be about
it's gonna be about languages that were
behind the cutting edge specifically
languages that were not even at the
forefront in the 1980s at the time of
the Apple 2 almost all the languages
that I'm gonna show you except of course
for Ruby we're really just kind of
common everyday place languages there
are nowhere near all the fancy stuff
they did back then all the tools that
I'm gonna show you are completely
useless you will never use them at your
job if you will use them at your job I
want to talk to you because you clearly
do something very interesting for a
living but what does this talk really
about it's about my quest to do
something that I would consider very
hard and very useless my two favorite
things to do in computer programming run
Ruby on the Apple to run a completely
modern programming language on an
absolutely outdated piece of hardware
if this talk is also about reminding
ourselves about how far we've come as
computer programmer it's even in the
past ten years our jobs have rather
dramatically changed and things have
gotten dramatically better so it's
important to remind ourselves kind of
what programming used to be like back in
the day and also this talk is about
having fun with computers maybe
everything that we do doesn't have to be
practical we can occasionally just do
projects for fun
so how many of you here have actually
used an apple two before Awesome's
that's a huge percentage of the audience
I actually am younger than almost all
models of Apple two that ever came out
this computer is actually made before I
was born however my grandparents had an
apple to see like the Apple to see
that's up here on stage and I remember
playing Tetris on that Apple to see and
I clearly remember that because well a
modern keyboard has the arrow keys laid
out like this and sort of the normal tea
organization the Apple SUSE lays them
out like this so you got left and right
and then down and then up and as a young
child I could not figure out how to play
Tetris with this weird layout the
original Apple 2 from 1977 an arrow key
layout like this didn't actually have up
and down Keys because why would you need
those I mean you can go forward and back
in your text and that's all you'd ever
need worse than that the original Apple
2 didn't actually have a delete key on
the keyboard you could just hit the back
key and rewrite over whatever you did
later models the app - like the app to
see here did add a delete key however
because the original software that's
kept inside the Apple 2 through all the
decades that it was produced need to be
on there for backwards compatibility
when you hit that delete key it doesn't
actually delete anything it instead just
types random characters on the screen it
was only more modern programmers that
would actually incorporate the Delete
key in their programs so as I said this
is an apple to see one of the later
models that came out it's the compact
version the Apple 2 has a 1 megahertz
clock in it and that was kind of carried
through all of the Apple twos except for
some much later ones that kind of gave
up on backwards compatibility and the
originals had as little as 8 kilobytes
of RAM to give you an idea of how small
that is
that was all of the RAM on the machine
it shared video ram with your program
and with all your execution data that
meant that with 8 kilobytes of RAM you
could barely do anything which is why
most people upgrade in this this model
here actually is a fair amount more RAM
than that an Apple ended up selling over
the course the Apple two's history in
all different variants about 5
- six million of these by some metrics
the Apple - is basically the most
successful line of computers ever made
being produced from 1977 all the way to
the mid-90s in all of its various
incarnations so since some of you here I
know may not be you know may not know as
much about how computers work another
hood I just want to give you brief
glossary of terms that I'm going to be
using throughout this talk a register is
a little bit of memory inside the CPU
and you can think of that like a
variable inside the CPU it's a little
space that you can store temporary
values and manipulate things whenever I
say register think of that like a
hardware equivalent of a variable in
your program you also have instructions
and opcodes instructions are like the
functions that a cpu can do so all of
the instructions that a CPU has defines
all of the things that can do like
addition multiplication moving data
around opcodes are the actual numerical
representations of all of those because
all that a computer does at the end of
the day is process numbers so every
little instruction is represented by
some number if you string together all
the numbers to represent your entire
program you have what's known as machine
code it is the raw binary that runs even
today to run all of your programs if you
translate that raw a binary all the
various hexadecimal values into
something a human can read and do a
one-to-one translation of it you have
what's known as assembly language
assembly language is kind of the
definition of a low-level programming
language you can directly look at
assembly and exactly figure out what
machine code instructions are going to
be created that isn't true for a
language like C in a language like C
even though we think of that as a very
low-level language if you write a switch
statement the compiler could end up
implementing that switch statement with
one of maybe twelve different algorithms
they all have various different bits of
assembly in order to run them already so
the computer that defines our current
time is the x86 64 processor and to
understand
the CPU inside of the Apple 2 it's
important to understand what our
modern-day computers can do with x86 64
processors that's basically all the CPUs
that you buy from Intel and AMD today
all the ones that are in our
tops and desktop computers it is what's
known as an out-of-order superscalar
computer which is really fun to say and
those are some fancy words what they
mean out of order there means that even
though your program consists of a
sequence of instructions at runtime the
cpu reorders all of those instructions
so for example if you do a bunch of
addition operations and then load from
memory the CPU may look at that and say
well loading from memory takes a long
time so why don't I just do that first
and then do all the addition operations
you want to be do first superscalar
means that more than one instruction can
run at the same time and at runtime the
CPU is figuring out how many
instructions it can do at once there are
little circuits inside the CPU that will
perform things like addition
multiplication and all that jazz the CPU
knows how many has available and it
looks at your program at runtime and
figures out how many of those
instructions it can actually execute all
at once so if you're doing an addition
and multiplication in a division those
are all separate circuits in your
computer at least in the case of some
computers and so if there's no data
dependencies between them an
out-of-order superscalar cpu may decide
that can run all of those instructions
at once at runtime even though you told
it to do them sequentially this is
really confusing I'm amazed that it
actually works but the reason why modern
CPUs are getting faster and faster and
faster isn't because the clock speeds
are getting faster as you may have
noticed it's because of tricks like this
where the CPU at runtime is taking
existing programs and trying to optimize
them as it's reading through the machine
code x86 64 the 64 there means that a
64-bit there are two meanings of 64-bit
here one is that the 16 which is a lot
general-purpose registers inside the CPU
can each store a 64-bit value so every
single variable that you have inside the
CPU every single register can store up
to 64 bits which is a heck of a lot and
general purpose here as far as registers
meaning that you can perform almost any
of the instructions available to you on
those registers there are some that are
a little bit more specialized but
basically all 16 of those 64 bit
registers can do almost anything in a
modern CPU
64 bit here also means that there is a
64-bit address space
so that means each address that looks
into memory can be up to 64 bits long
that allows you to address exabytes of
memory exabytes are ridiculously large I
would be willing to bet that within our
lifetime none of us will ever need an
exabyte of memory unless you were doing
the very very top end of supercomputer
work maybe in the distant future your
home CPU is and never have an exabyte of
memory so this 64 address space is gonna
last us for a very very long time mind
you those are famous last words whenever
someone has said computers are powerful
off now but I'm gonna stand by x86 64 is
over a thousand instructions depending
on how you count it over a thousand
things that the CPU can do and that
number is growing as things like
cryptography requirements as well as
graphic requirements mean they keep
adding more and more specialized
instructions instead I having to write
out multiple instructions to do a
command you can use a very specialized
one to do exactly what you want
now these instructions look like things
like ink increment which just takes a
value in a register and adds one to at a
relatively common operation which is why
it has its own instruction mow the
multiply command take maybe a value from
memory and a value in a register
multiply them together store them in a
another register and then other commands
like this one this sub add okay so this
is a fuse multi sorry fuse multiply
alternating subtract slash add of packed
double precision floating points the
majority of those a thousand commands in
x86 are weird super specialized things
like this now you may not have to do
this very often but your compiler may
see like oh man instead of like doing a
bunch of instructions here I could just
do one fuse multiply alternating at
subtract slash add of pack double
precision floating point values and then
hey there's one instruction that does
that I actually have no idea what that
instruction doesn't so we're gonna move
on all right what's inside the Apple 2
is the 6502 processor this is an amazing
processor arguably it is the processor
that defined the home computing era
because this is the processor that
really got the home computing revolution
going you'll find in the Apple 2 you'll
find in the commodore 64 you will also
find in
systems like the Nintendo Entertainment
System the 6502 is a very simple
microprocessor it takes an instruction
and then it interprets it and then it
executes sit no out of order stuff no
parallelism nothing like that it simply
takes your code and executes it exactly
as you have written it it is an 8-bit
CPU but it has a 16-bit address space
that means every variable that you can
deal with is only 8 bits long the 16-bit
address space causes problems because to
address memory you can't actually store
an entire memory address in one register
and it doesn't let you fuse two
registers together to get 16-bit values
instead you have to say like look at
this page in memory and then offset by
this register value or you can load like
a literal 16-bit so if you know exactly
where that byte is gonna be in memory
ahead of time you can hard code that but
other than that you kinda have to jump
through hoops just to even get it things
in memory because of the fact that it's
a 16-bit address space but each register
is only eight bits and what about those
registers you have zero general-purpose
registers some people say that there's
one but I would say that one register
isn't a general purpose register because
you can't actually do everything on it
it is you have one 8-bit accumulator so
you can do things like addition on it
you can't actually do subtraction you
can't do multiplication those are you
know too fancy but you can do addition
on it and you also can't do increment or
decrement it's relatively limited in
what can do but it's designed to give
you kind of all the basic mathematical
operations that you would need you then
have two 8-bit index registers and while
those can't be used for fancy things
like addition you can do increment and
decrement on them and those are the
registers that you can use to kind of do
offsets and lookup into memory and so
you have three non general-purpose
registers that you kind of have to
juggle with and I don't know if you've
ever tried to write a program only using
three mutable variables it's kind of
hard and it's a little bit of a juggling
act and you can't run into a lot of bugs
where you know things don't work because
you accidentally reused a register it
has 56 instructions sort of the reason
why I say sort of is because well you
didn't have any multiply dividers
operations those 56 originally you
didn't have a rotate right instruction
and so they originally quoted as having
55 instructions that's because there was
an actual bug on the chip that they
originally manufactured the cause rotate
right to just fail horribly and so they
said cool it has 55 instructions and
then a little bit later they're like and
now we have a new version with 56
instructions Wow
however what made the 6502 really
amazing was those fast it couldn't do
very much but what it did it did very
very quickly and it was cheap at the
time that it came out it was one sixth
of the price of all other micro
processors on the market and they kind
of forced every other manufacturer out
there to really drive all their prices
down thus kind of causing the home
computer revolution 6502 is also a
hobbyist dream it was cheap it was fun
to program with because you had to do
all these weird tricks just to get it to
do anything useful and one of those
hobbyists who played around with 6502
early on was a guy named Steve Wozniak
who ended up founding Apple Steve
Wozniak was a master of really simple
engineering solutions at the start of
this talk when I turned this computer on
you may have heard a banging sound of
the floppy disk that is because this
floppy disk drive does not actually have
a position sensor the computer doesn't
actually have a sensor to say which
actual track on the floppy disk it's
reading so this was to save money cuz I
would have cost money so instead the
floppy disk drive at start up rams
itself against one of the side walls and
keeps ramming itself until it's
absolutely sure it's at the start and
then it's your responsibility as a
programmer every time you move the read
head to keep track of where it actually
is this makes it harder on the
programmer but it does mean that they
could save costs in manufacturing now
was couldn't actually afford an in
circuit emulator or an assembler and in
those fancy things you might use to do
development work and so he wrote his own
monitor program in raw machine code he
wrote a program that will let him
directly input values into memory and
see was in memory and disassemble it
wrote all that by hand and then
use that to implement the first version
of basic and so I would like to show you
what it is like to program using
something like a machine monitor so I'm
going to exit out of my slides and go
into the go in the mini monitor here we
have a little bit of prompt and I can
say for example six five four and what
it printed out there is that at address
six five four in memory you have the
byte a one we can also set bytes in
memory and so what you do is you would
write down your program using a pen and
paper if you're feeling adventurous or a
pencil and paper if you're someone like
me write down the algorithm you want to
do figure out what are all the
instructions that would be required to
do that then you use a lookup table
translate that a machine code and then
type it into the machine which looked a
little bit something like this so at
address 800 I'm going to type in a colon
which means that I'm gonna go ahead and
edit the actual memory starting address
800 so first I want to load a literal
value of 16 into the Y register so the
load - Y with literal is the a 0 command
and then I'm gonna let me this out of
space here a 0 and then a 10 is the
literal hexadecimal value of the number
16 so that I want to load the a register
with something out of memory and so I'm
gonna type in B 9 0 B 0 8 and appending
you catch any typos please let me know
as I need to store it which is 9 9 0 0 0
5 I'm storing it address 500 but at 0 0
0 5 because it's little-endian for those
of you who are interested alrighty and
then I'm gonna go ahead and do a
decrement operation which is 88 and then
I'm gonna do a branch if that decrement
happened to hit zero which is d0 and I'm
going to branch back to f7 then a branch
instruction isn't this exciting this is
what programming was like for Steve
Wozniak back in the 1970s it gets even
more exciting because as any Lister will
tell you programs are just data and your
data in your program exists in the same
place and there's no better way to learn
that with the
so now I'm gonna hand type in a little
bit bit of data and those of you who
happen to know the Apple to character
set
don't don't spoil anyone what I'm typing
in all right so I typed in that double
zero so I'm going to do 48 49 and 60
this is where it starts getting really
fun 53 54 52 41 for e 47 I know you guys
are just absolutely thrilled at this and
you can imagine how nervous I am doing
live machine code up here on stage 4 C 4
F I always forget the second floor F but
this time I remembered it 50 and then 61
I hit enter and it wrote all that into
memory isn't that exciting now thank you
now back in the day this is what people
would do and in universities the general
that graduate students would do someone
would hand them here's all the machine
code and they would hand type all this
stuff in one of Von Neumanns graduate
student was a man by the name of I think
his last name is sprouts Donald Geils he
in his free time wrote a little program
that actually would let him just type in
you know a human readable version
assembly code and would translate that
into us when von Neumann found out that
he had done this he scolded him because
computer should not be used for clerical
work you need to learn how to hand type
all this stuff in because that really
teaches you to feel what the computer is
doing I'm really glad that history
proved von Neumann wrong so there's been
enough suspense I bet you're wondering
what this program does I'm wondering
what it does because it depends on if I
typed it in correctly so I'm going to
say 800 so that's where the program
starts and then AG which says execute
starting at that line of memory I hit
enter and you see it prints out strange
loop to this or uh whoa
it should okay upper left corner you see
it's a strange loop exclamation point
awesome
obviously I did something wrong here you
see
so the screen has gone a little bit
confused no worries just gonna go ahead
and clear that out quickly awesome I'm
not gonna fix that program for you live
however if we hit 800 L it'll
disassemble the program and you go ahead
and look at here and actually it may be
a relatively simple fix but we are going
to skip past that because I don't want
to waste all your time but it printed
strangely for the screen so there you go
semi working code now you know what
programming really was like already so
what was it that let me go back to my
slides one moment already gonna go ahead
sorry next I'm gonna go into basic so
I'm gonna command B and enter the
programming language that steve wozniak
entirely implemented this way was a
version of basic it's a relatively
limited version of basic and so later
they replace it with a really fancy one
from a small company you may have heard
of called Microsoft and this is what
became known as Apple soft basic and
Apple saw basic is kind of and basic in
general was sort of a language that was
like a lingua Franca's like the Python
of its day and most people who learn
programming learn to program using basic
and in some ways it resembles
programming languages like we have today
so if I say X equals 10 and then print X
it prints out the number 10 nice
you also strings and basic ooh fancy so
if I take in pugs
equals cute and hit enter it gives me a
type mismatch error and the reason for
that is the variables that you do for
Strings are actually stored in a
separate space as the variables that you
do for integers and the way you have to
write this out is pugs and then a dollar
sign and then equals cute now it works
and I can say print hugs dollar sign
and a printout cute awesome let me
define another variable for fun here I'm
gonna say poppers dollar sign equals
also cute cool and I can print out
hoppers dollar signs and it says also
cute awesome something like define
multiple variables except there is a bug
in this program I know it doesn't seem
like there's a bug here but there is a
bug if I do print hugs dollar sign it
prints out also cute
Apple soft basic was great and I have
variable names of any length except it
only looked at the first two characters
of the variable and so because cogs and
poppers both start with the letters P
and you it stores in the same place in
memory and I'm assuming this made
programming really fun alrighty now to
go back to my slides I'm gonna type in
Paul 1016 there's a chance because of
that bug the admin before this may not
work hey it went back to my slides for
the record there is not a like
multi-multi process operating system
running here I just am trying to write
all this codes that they happen to not
overwrite the same locations in memory
really fun to try and get that one
working alright so going back to the
slides
alright so I know about you but I think
Ruby would be a much more fun
programming language to have on the
Apple - I mean Ruby is much easier to
learn programming language and even if
you don't like Ruby surely you must
think it's gonna be easier than the
weird stuff to have to put up with in
something like basic so how are we gonna
do this well you may think well there's
a see Ruby implementation that's the
main one see Ruby so let's just compile
that C code and run it on the Apple -
everything will be great it will not
because see Ruby expects certain things
expects things like Unicode and
obviously the Apple 2 came out before
Unicode even existed in thus it doesn't
support Unicode characters and that's
kind of built in to see Ruby core be
really hard to tear that out syrupy also
expects asking
Apple 2 doesn't use ASCII it actually
uses a weird subset of ASCII where they
took a small sample of it and then
repeated it four times one is the actual
characters one is an inverted version of
all those characters one is a flashing
version of those characters so you can
do things like flashing cursors and then
there is another one that's repeated I
don't actually know what that one was
intended for but it prints out exactly
the same just regular characters also
fun fact on the original opportunity you
didn't have like curly brackets which
means we can't even get regular Ruby
syntax working cuz we're not gonna have
curly brackets see Ruby's binary is also
three megabytes in size we have a we
have a 16-bit address space we can't
even address that much memory
technically we could like create a
special language card with a like a
Raspberry Pi on it that sort of switched
out memory and did all the fancy stuff
for us but then that wouldn't really be
running Ruby on here now so you may know
that there's an alternative version of
Ruby called am Ruby M Ruby is an
embeddable version of Ruby it's designed
to work on microprocessors and very
small CPUs if you haven't played with it
before it's really fun it's kind of like
you can do like Arduino style
programming except in Ruby so M really
was made to fit on small CPUs like this
so surely it's a good choice it's still
too big because it turns out even like
the little micro processors that get
used in thermostats and things like that
beats days often have more RAM than the
Apple 2 does and C is also too
high-level language one of the reasons
why they're so big is because the 6502
wasn't really a good language for c to
target there are a bunch of things that
c expects to be relatively simple to do
where you have to do all kinds of weird
memory lookups to make it happen on the
6502 processor so instead writing in
sembly is a much better choice because
we can directly control exactly what the
processor is doing and optimize it down
to the smallest thing possible so it's
all hope lost or we're not going to be
able to actually squeeze Ruby onto the
Apple to see know which is why I have
been working on creating an Ruby for the
Apple to a completely useless very or a
completely useless very in
to have a very useful programming
language it's all the joy of Ruby the
packed into a really really really small
space my target is to get it so that it
can actually work with only eight
kilobytes of RAM to hold your program
all of your program data and the actual
interpreter itself as I said before it's
written entirely in assembly which is
the only way to really make this work
and is actually relatively normal for
programming on these old machines mames
asked what the N and N Ruby stands for
it kind of stands for nano but the main
reason why it's called M Ruby is because
um n is half of an M so if n Ruby is a
smaller version of M Ruby we're gonna
call it n Ruby which that makes sense
when you write it down but we say it out
loud it just sounds like you're saying
the same word over and over so what does
n Ruby need it needs Ruby's flexible
syntax because you're not really a ruby
programming language unless you could do
all sorts of you do the same thing in
all sorts of different ways depending on
what you need so for example having the
parenthesis optional for function calls
needs to be pure object oriented
everything needs to be an object that
actually makes our jobs a lot easier we
don't need to create a bunch of separate
data types we can kind of create one
object data type and then specialize it
very slightly to do the things you need
for things like integers and numbers it
needs all the features that we love
modules blocks the numerals eval IRB to
have an interactive way to program with
it
it needs to be more dynamic than anyone
needs knieval to redefine everything
again that's actually not that hard
because we're writing all these
subroutines in order to define things on
objects so we can just expose those to
the program or is this thing that you
can actually use and it also needs
dynamic memory allocation and a garbage
collector no this is where I have to
tell you about what happened last night
when I was trying to get the last bit of
this talk ready I was having a lot of
compiler problems and until about 4:00
a.m. was trying to debug all the things
that were going wrong so instead of
showing you a test suite which passes an
emulator but for some reason does not
pass when I run it on actual hardware I
managed to put together on
f of n Ruby and reassemble it so that I
can give you this demo
unfortunately I've switched floppy discs
so if you hold on one moment you note
the tech stays on screen that's because
after that initial floppy disk noises
it's loaded everything in a memory the
floppy disk isn't doing anything up to
this point with the presentation pop in
the Emma Ruby floppy disk I'm gonna go
ahead and restart the machine to load
that floppy disk I love that clapping
sound alright do you and Ruby and we're
actually running low on time because
that technical difficulties we had
initially so I'm going to call binary
run of and Ruby takes a little bit to
load we go ahead and get into a prompt
so I can show you you can put hello and
it prints hello
[Applause]
this may not seem very impressive I
don't know how many of you out there
have ever tried to write a parser in a
modern programming language it's not
very easy writing it in assembly on the
other hand whole other thing
so just in order to parse this figure
out the objects and allocate those
objects into memory and then you know
use the call stack in order to print it
you would not believe how much machinery
is involved and do this doing this I'm
actually amazed that it runs as fast as
it does right now we also have flexible
syntax so I'm like basic we can say it's
open parens call it like a function call
and it goes ahead and crits that out too
and again unfortunately you have to pop
this out now and go back to slides tell
you a little bit about how all this is
working under the hood
oops if you turn it on too fast after
turning it off everything is still in
memory and it just arrows out and
hilariously doesn't give another moment
turn it back on slides slides up again
is exciting there we go go ahead and
skip ahead there we go
alright so inside main implemented of an
Ruby had to implement dynamic memory
allocation as well as a garbage
collector but because it's Ruby I want
to make sure that you could you know
create as many objects as you want it I
don't want to give you those arbitrary
limitations of this many of this many
objects and this many of this many
objects I wanted all different data
types to be stored in one heap like you
would in any ordinary Ruby so you can
make as many of those different objects
as you want however you can make as many
as you want as long as you want
256 objects max it's actually less than
256 because you also have objects like
false and nil and the class class which
are all create initial ization so
technically it's less than that but I'm
pretty sure that none of you here ever
need to write a program that uses a more
than 256 objects and just ignore the
fact that if you actually count the
number of
objects in Ruby when it initially starts
before it runs any code its orders of
magnitude larger than this but you know
it's fine you don't have to do an
amazing amount with only 256 objects so
how is it that I write this code I'm not
going in there and actually typing all
this on a vintage computer that is a
terrible idea
instead modern development on the
aptitude works a little bit differently
sorry you may think that all this is
gonna be really hard to do there's gonna
be like really difficult to write this
program I would argue that actually
getting Apple Tara Ruby running in the
upper two is not that hard because
writing the language is a really big
tasks actually trying to write one
assembly but you can just break it down
into smaller tasks for example writing a
parser an assembly that is ridiculously
difficult however if you go ahead and
try and write that same instead of the
whole parse or just write a thing that
can parse strings a thing that can parse
integers actually each of those tasks is
a little bit easier you build all those
up over time and then eventually you
have an entire parser so the key to this
is being patient and breaking everything
down into relatively small tasks however
well it isn't hard it is super super
tedious there's just a lot of grunt work
you have to do in order to do all this
assembly programming most of that is
debugging time whenever something goes
wrong you can't just like put in a bunch
of print statements see what all the
variables are instead you have to in the
case of modern development open it up in
an emulator inspect the entire memory
map figure out where it's going long
step by step by step through all the
assembly but eventually you can figure
out where your problem lies now I've
done a lot of like weird programming
projects like this and I have learned
over time that there is one secret for
doing these like really challenging
programming projects or things that you
know seem like they might not
necessarily work for example once I
implemented the entire game of chess and
a chess AI only using untyped lambda
calculus and in all these projects thing
that makes it easy is test-driven
development it's the same thing that
makes work easy now you may say
test-driven development assembly is that
is that possible yes it is it's just
that your tests are basically asserting
that you run a subroutine and then
look at the value in the a register and
the depending on it matches something
you've heard Co and the test print out a
character to the screen whether it
passes or fails then run your tests it
prints out a bunch of characters of the
screen and then go through your code and
figure out where all those failing
characters are which actual tests is
that line up with it's a little bit
tedious but it makes things a lot easier
because it means you're free to kind of
rewrite the code as much as you want and
as long as you're preserving all those
api's that your tests are expecting
everything works well I know this may
seem obvious but when talking to a lot
of friends who do similar projects they
were surprised that anyone actually do
test-driven development in assembly so
to actually get this program up and
running and do development you first
want to just write all that assembly on
your laptop use a modern text editor
it's way better you'll get things like
code coloring and autocomplete it's
great if I'm going to go ahead and
assemble the binary take that raw
assembly code and turn it into a machine
code binary however you can't just load
that into an emulator or something like
that you need to actually put it onto a
disk or a virtual disk so next thing is
to run another program that creates a
disk image with that binary on it that
puts all the file structure and things
around it names the file so that the
computer can actually recognize that
binary and then run it you then need to
go ahead and test that disk in an
emulator assuming it all works you then
transfer it over via serial cable like
this USB to rs-232 serial cable I have
here of course the app to see doesn't
actually have rs-232 because that wasn't
super common computer at the time so you
then need to plug that into this rs-232
to no modem port cable if any of you
actually has these at home again I want
to talk to you cuz you're clear a very
interesting person but there's someone
online who still sells these things
which is very very useful you can then
go ahead and once you transfer all that
disdain over you can use another program
to write that out to the floppy disk I
have to use the Apple 2 to write things
onto the floppy disk because I don't
know of a five and a quarter inch floppy
disk drive that will write Apple two
compatible floppy disks and also has a
USB port so I can plug it into my
computer so the emulator they use is one
called virtual 2 it is great because it
has a lot of debugging features
to get access to a lot of those you do
have to use a paid version but I want to
support this developer because they
created a really cool Apple 2 emulator
even if you want will simulate that sort
of clunking sounds of the disk drive and
the green of phosphorous display the
assembler that I use is the Merlin 32
assembler Merlin 32 is interesting
because it even though I believe it was
last updated 2015 its descendant of an
assembler called Merlin 16 which is a
descendant of a long line of Merlin
assemblers going all the way back to the
original Merlin assembler which was
written on an apple 2 for compiling to
the Apple 2 it's actually descended from
an original vintage assembler I found
that it's the easiest assembler to use
and the easiest to get going with is
Merlin 32 and it has reasonably good
documentation however there's also an
assembler called CC 65 well Merlin 32 is
a little bit more targeted towards the
Apple family CC 65 will let you compile
onto many different things like the
commodore 64 the apple 2 thing you can
also do like nes on there however CC 65
is also more difficult to use so just
fair warning that's why i chose not to
use it
apple commander is a program which lets
you from the command line
take a 6502 binary and put it into a
disk image on your machine it will
generate those disk images for you it is
written in Java which I find hilarious
that my build chain involves Java in
order to get things working on the Apple
2 but hey whoever wrote that thank you
it is a free open-source tool and it is
absolutely amazing and wonderful to use
then the program that actually transfers
that data over the serial line is a
program called ADP sorry ADT Pro it has
a client on your laptop and then you
plug in a serial cable you type in a
couple assembly commands it then
bootstraps the entire program over into
your Apple 2 and then from there opens
up a nice GUI that you can use to
actually take things off of your
filesystem
and load them into the apple 2 and then
also gives you a function which you can
call to write that out to disk
another really fantastic programming has
a hilariously kind of out of 8 UI and I
believe it's
also written in Java I don't know why
there's so many Java developers doing
this stuff but again thanks to all of
them so assembly is a really difficult
programming language to work in and
we're kind of running low on time I can
tell you if you haven't yet play with
assembly it is actually a surprisingly
easy programming language to learn why
do I say that well it's cuz it can only
really do one of three things especially
on a cpu like this you can do a thing to
a register you know multiply two
registers or you can think of them like
variables together you can do a thing to
a byte in memory so you can say take
this register and store it here in
memory or take this location in memory
and load it into this register and then
you can jump around in your code you can
say you know if this particular register
is equal to this value move to this
other line of code it really doesn't do
that much which means it's actually
easier to learn assembly than is almost
any other programming language the
difficulty with assembly is figure out
how to translate that relatively small
number of things into a working program
the syntax is also easy it's divided
into three columns the middle one is the
only required one the other two are
optional you have a label that's just a
helpful thing that lets you say at this
particular line in the machine code you
can use that as a variable to jump back
to elsewhere in your code you have the
mnemonic which is the fancy name for the
function that you're calling it's a
translation of the opcode into something
that is readable for humans and then
optionally some commands we'll also take
an argument be pass in so here we have a
very simple line of assembly code it
just says a CLC which is sort of for
clear carry here's a more complicated
one LD a load the a register and then
the argument we have a pound sign which
means a literal value whatever number
follows is exactly why I transfer and
we're not gonna load from memory the
dollar sign means it's in hexadecimal
and in this case it's just zero so we're
going to load the literal value of zero
in da register the next line I have a
label there loop I can use that later to
loop back to that line all that that
label does it says whatever whatever bit
of code follows next store the address
of that as it is in memory so that then
I can use that as a variable later when
I want to jump back to that address so
here I'm comparing with another
a constant called count which could have
been defined early in the program and
then a branch if not equal xub and that
will if if that comparison operation
ended up with something it wasn't equal
we'll go ahead and branch back to the
loop so very end here I want to give you
a small idea of what's happening
underneath the hood here in n Ruby and
one of the easiest things to understand
is the memory management model so inside
of n Ruby as I said you have 256 objects
now those 256 objects they're not really
objects they're like little slots in
memory that you can store a data into it
is 16 bytes long so every little chunk
of memory that we're going to be
managing a 16 bytes long and we can fit
16 of those onto a 256 bit page and so
we end up having is this sort of table
in memory we start at page n and then we
have one 16-bit slot followed by another
16-bit slot and then on page n plus 1 we
have more until eventually we have 16
pages each with 16 slots and each of
those slots has 16 bytes of memory and
thus we end up with 256 spots available
now we need to have a unique number for
these one of the reason why we have 256
slots is it means we can uniquely
represent every single object with an
8-bit value that means that because as
an 8-bit processor we can very quickly
kind of do lookups on objects the
simplest number scheme and the one that
I started with is starting on the first
page we're going to go ahead and just
have the first hop be called slot 0 and
then the next one be called 1 and the 2
3 4 5 6 we just go through all the slots
and numbering them sequentially now we
can uniquely identify each one with a
number so let's say that we want to
address the memory in slot CF CF would
represent the 240th byte or F 0 of the
12th page 0 see the reason why I see all
those 16 is because this means look
there we want to address the CF slot and
that's on the f0 byte and the 0 C page
and so we just need to take that
move it over to the lower nibble take
that F move it up to the upper nipple
and now we've translated our unique
integer representation for that slot
into an actual byte and page in memories
so the assembly for that looks like this
the main thing to look at here is
they're all those ASL and LSI those are
arithmetic shift left and logical shift
right so we're doing is we're taking
that C value we're shifting it all the
way over to the left and in that
shifting that's zero idents of clearing
out with zeros as it goes and so we move
that upper nibble to the lower nibble
that gives us our page and then the next
part with all those LS RS we take that F
nibble and we shift it over to the right
in order to move it into the F zero slot
okay so there's a lot of repeated
instructions in here and this is way
slower than I would like it to be so
what if instead of laying out our memory
like this the logical way where each
slot is numbered in order what if we
rotate it 90 degrees so if we were to
write sequentially to each slot in
memory we first write to the first slot
on page N and then the first slot on
page n plus one and then the first slot
on page n plus 2 all the way until
eventually run out of pages and then we
loop back they go to the second slot on
page n to write our 16th slot so we've
just kind of taken our representation
before rotated and flipped it 90 degrees
when we do that you'll notice that now
the byte that were writing to that C is
in the same position as it is in our
integer representation and in the page
you'll notice the F there that gives us
the page that that particular C F
address goes to is actually in the same
position the nipples are in the exact
same place so instead of having to shift
that C over and shift that EFT over to
translate our address instead what we
can do is just do an and operation just
kind of wipe out with zeros to see on
one side that gives us one value and
then wipe out the F on the other side
that gives us the other value so again
here's our program before and here's our
program afterwards
assembly programming is doing a lot of
little things like this you right now
algorithm you get it
to work and then you figure out if you
play around with the numbers if there's
a smaller and faster way to write your
program so what's next for n Ruby I'd
like to finish up version 1.0 obviously
and I'm working very actively on that
the reason why n Ruby isn't on github
right now is because there are a couple
of little libraries in there that it's
using currently for its developing it
that are actually not open source and so
legally I don't want to get in trouble
for releasing not open source software
however in version 1.1 or 1.0 I'm going
to strip all that out so that I can put
up a github if you want you to follow me
on Twitter I'll announce it when it
finally comes out once I do have it
working I am curious to try getting and
Ruby working on other processors I'm
especially interested in the msp430
which is a really cool microprocessor
that's a more modern one especially
those you get super low-power variants
so for example you can have a
microprocessor that runs on a lemon with
a copper plate and a zinc plate put in
it like you see in science class I would
love the idea of Ruby this like heavy
weight inefficient programming language
running on the power of a lemon I think
that would be fantastic and also the
msp430 is more powerful so it's a little
bit easier to write code for it I also
want to try getting and working on other
computers that use the 6502 especially
the NES the Nintendo Entertainment
System wouldn't be go to write a game
that runs in Ruby and that Ruby is
actually running on the Nintendo
Entertainment System the thing that's
gonna make this very challenging and the
reason why I mix it in it is the nes
only had two kilobytes of RAM so that's
where all your data would go and then
your source code would be in 40
kilobytes of problem so you have a lot
of ROM space you don't have that much
space actually store the object so be
relatively interesting at least for me
to do that so thank you so much for all
of your time if you have any questions
feel free to speak
[Applause]